people mistake activity for progress 99  of the decisions that we make are  relevant for the ultimate outcome that  we're looking at and i think it's really  trying to figure out where do i have the  most leverage and then being very  patient on pulling that one lever that  one big move and most of the people that  i see that are very far in life have  very low activity but when they do take  an action they go all in or they make a  very significant bet on that action  because they know that they have limited  bandwidth right so they put way more of  their time in thinking about the bet and  so they can replace the activity with  the thought process because wealth is a  relationship with time people who have  tremendous wealth have a mastery of time